welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and after re-watching spider-man no
way home again one curiosity that i'm
now obsessing over is how exactly the
film's ending leaves the rainy verse
that toby mcguire and doc ock and norman
osborne return to like there's the
question of how far doctor strange's
memory wipe spell extends like does
kirsten dunst mj remember peter does doc
ock of that reality remember peter i
think so like dr strange's magic wi-fi
can't go that far otherwise strange
would be way too insanely powerful over
franchises kevin feige doesn't yet have
unlimited power over yet but the detail
we haven't talked enough about was the
fact that doc ock ends this movie with
the power of the sun finally in the palm
of his hand in the form of a tony stark
arc reactor that he snatched from
electro and then appears to fade back to
that rainy versus reality with still in
his hand so is stark tech now in the
rainy verse well i'm gonna break down
exactly how no way ohm wants us to think
about this and specifically how this one
loose detail could fix a lot of our
biggest concerns left over about doc ock
and his fate the multiverse logic of no
way home dictates that whatever
technological upgrades characters
underwent while in the mcu stays with
them physically as they return home doc
ox fixed inhibitor chip via the stark
fabricator norman osborne's anti-goblin
serum that he got injected with
electro's electric restrainer bolt thing
lizards restoration serum and sandman's
collider therapy all left them with
permanent fixes and during those final
beats the battle otto octavius marvels
over the ark reactor that he pulled off
of electro and echoes his big line the
power of the sun and then toby maguire
peter parker finishes in the palm of
your hand this is the last we see of
otto until he fades but if he fades back
to the raimi burst with the stark tech
of the fixed inhibitor chip in the back
of his neck wouldn't he also fade back
with the stark tech still in his hand
like think about it the movie did not
have to show otto holding that arc
reactor like that it could have been as
simple as docot clawed it out of max's
chest and then we just never saw it in
frame from there forward but the film
deliberately wanted us to see otto still
possessing this arc reactor moments
before his cross-dimensional return trip
and i think there is a reason for that
moment not to concern us that otto
octavius might now be at risk of
becoming drunk with power once more but
instead to give him a potential fix to
the most critical crisis this character
still must face the destabilizing fusion
reaction in that boathouse that still
threatens to swallow the whole city now
has your life recently been boring and
lacking in orcs ice golems and thrilling
combat we'll fix that by downloading
this video sponsor read shadow legends
here's the links below to download raid
to your mobile phone or your pc because
raid just introduced a new hydra boss
this thing has six heads and each of
them has different powers and effects
the head of blight poisons your team
we're the head of wraith loves the movie
seven because what's in the box massive
damages in that box you will also have
to deal with the head of torment the
head of mischief the head of decay and
the head of suffering they each bring
their own challenges to overcome a
favorite part of raid is a huge number
of champions there are hundreds in the
game and they're always adding more i
don't have hundreds of friends and i
never had any more and look at all the
champions in the index they have the
tomb angel more like they had the tomb
angle of those curves raid's giving away
a limited edition champion to every
player esports legend simple between now
and january 28th simples champ is
available for free to both new and old
players log in for seven days between
now and january 28th and he is yours and
on top of that raid's got special new
year's events and tournaments and a new
faction wars crypt opening there's never
been a better time to get started and if
you use our link in the description or
scan the qr code you'll get a free
starter pack worth almost 30 dollars to
kickstart your game a free champion
vergas 200 000 silver one energy refill
one xp boost and one ancient shard to
summon your awesome champions as soon as
you get a game all of this treasure will
be waiting for you right here
once you're in you can find us in-game
under the name newrock2020 and if you're
fast you can join our clan it's easy
just click the link in the description
and we'll see you in the game because
remember earlier in the film otto said
that he transferred into this reality
the moment he had peter by the throat he
was referring to the moment in 2004
spider-man 2 in that boathouse right
before peter's words echoed from ant-may
woke up otto from his nightmare and gave
him the strength to take back control of
his claws also in no way home when he
first met mcu peter on that bridge he
asked what have you done with my machine
this tells us that that fusion reaction
was still his primary present concern
and a problem that he will still have to
deal with when he goes back to that
reality i have wondered that auto
octavius even with his humanity restored
might still have been doomed to death
because he would still have to drag that
chaotic reaction into the river drowning
alongside it but now i'm not so sure
because this arc reactor loose end
forces us to consider that otto might be
conceiving of a way to patch that fusion
reaction so that his machine now runs on
the stark arc reactor instead of on the
erratic tritium that he obtained from
oscorp in that movie for otto octavius
in 2004's spider-man 2 and for tony
stark and the iron man films and 2012's
avengers their goals were the same to
give society a clean renewable energy
source think back on the opening scenes
of the avengers movie they show tony
stark finally using his arc reactor
technology to ignite this energy
throughout the grid of manhattan
stemming from that beacon of avengers
tower completing the dream that otto
octavius in another universe fell short
of and now otto has in the palm of his
hand that same generation of arc reactor
the one electro grab from happy's condo
has the triangular inlay meaning this is
the specific generation of arc reactor
that tony constructed in iron man 2 the
reactor that powered his mark vi suit at
the end of iron man 2 and at the
beginning of the avengers and powered
the mark 7 suit that tony upgrades into
during the course of the avengers film
this reactor is more refined using the
new element that tony rediscovered in
iron man 2 so it doesn't have the
poisonous radiation of his earlier model
but the reactor isn't overpowered enough
to be dangerous either it's kind of in
that sweet spot of capacity to power a
city the way otto octavius hoped tritium
would so how could otto use this arc
reactor to stop a miniature sun in a
boathouse just kind of throw it in i
don't know that'd probably result in a
bigger boom boom
but from an engineering perspective the
real reason otto's fusion reaction lost
control wasn't the reaction itself it
was really his machine wasn't properly
calibrated to restrain those energy
spikes the reason he needed those freaky
extra arms is that they were made of a
certain metal resistant to heat and
magnetism which allowed him to manually
keep at bay the random flares that
bursted out of that reaction gotta say
not the best plan otto so when his
poorly calibrated machine got
overwhelmed and one of those flares
fried the inhibitor chip he then had no
way of restraining the fusion's
expansion really the only way toby's
spider-man could stop it was by pulling
the machine's plugs giving that reaction
no energy field to grow anymore and so
the reaction died out therefore what
otto would need to stop this fusion
reaction the boathouse is an alternate
energy source to swap in place and then
keep his machine running at the proper
input level leaving the fusion reaction
with nothing to feed on so then the
fusion would zero out the way it did at
the earlier accident and now auto has
that patch in the form of a stark arc
reactor using his heat resistant arms
now in his control he could extend that
arc reactor to the base of his machine
and rewire it to bypass the tech from
the tritium to the safer startech i will
admit doc hot potatoing in an arc
reactor like indiana jones swapping in
the idol for a sandbag isn't the most
foolproof fix for this mess but alt
universe alfred molina was right there
for that raider scene so the guy has
learned this transplant maneuver from
the best this would leave the universe
that auto octavius returns to not only
with a fixed auto but with a fully
realized dream of a city now capable of
running on clean energy a multiverse
saved once again by the mind of tony
stark support new rockstars by checking
out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
the rockstars subscribe to the rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thank you for watching and now you may
return to what you were doing holding
the power of your sons in the palm of
your hand
[Music]
you